if you're consistently thinking about
quitting you have to understand the
reason why is it because you're afraid
or is it because you don't want to do
things people stay in things too long
like when people say don't quit don't
quit people should off often quit on
businesses sooner relationships sooner
jobs sooner because you'll never win
doing work that you hate but if the
reason that you're quitting is because
you're afraid that's not a good enough
reason and so where
I am challenging myself to do the most
work is
on
thinking like the biggest frustration
for me is okay so if I'm at three and a
half million subscribers how do I get to
35 right and how do I live in that Vibe
consistently